and Victoria thank you so much for
calling in to speak to us here this
afternoon and no talk to me about what
happened to your dad
um
I think it was about 7th of August
um I sort of went to his flat and found
him in a bit of a state so I called 999
um and they were there literally within
half an hour so you know that was a
great positive
um they looked after him they took him
to hospital and he had some gastric
stomach gastric infection that was
causing him to be quite poorly
um so they kind of gave him antibiotics
and fluids and that was all okay and
then I was told you know your dad can go
home but he was quite frail so he would
need some sort of care package to go
home with
um and that never came and this went on
and on and then he kind of got covered a
couple of times he'd never had it before
he's always been really careful so that
was disappointing
um and then he got over that and again
was ready to go home again and then
again no care package and then just
before New Years
um he got like a proper flu so he was
isolated into a sort of separate room we
could still go and visit
um we did sort of usual PP and
everything and then the flu who went to
his chest he got a chest infection and
sort of the first week of Jan he
developed pneumonia and he passed away
on the 6th of Jan through pneumonia
oh Victoria first of all I'm so sorry
for your loss
um but just listening to all of that
your father was waiting for five months
yeah to be discharged from hospital we
originally went in with stomach problems
correct and then he he died in hospital
from unrelated Matters from absolutely
yeah from what you've been saying yeah
um talk to me about how that happened
you mentioned a care package and that
wasn't able to be put in place now I
know what a lot of people may say to you
Victoria just of curiosity you know your
father clearly had family had you he may
have had other members of family and why
couldn't he go home what kind of care
did he need and it wasn't being given by
the NHS that made him stay in hospital
for five months he needed very sort of
intimate Personal Care
um so he'd lost control of his bowel
after having this gastric infection so
he was wearing sort of incontinence part
sort of like almost like nappies really
um and he also
um had got very frail he was had a lot
of muscle wastage while he was in
hospital
um he was having some kidney problems as
well
um he was kind of waiting to see his
kidney doctor all this time so they were
desperate to get him home so because
there were other symptoms he was quite
anemic there's other problems but just
just things that you know I know she's
got specific medical training
um it's not something that just a family
member could pick up and he needed to
sort of care with everything you know
getting up his personal care washing
um where he lived wasn't really suitable
so that was another thing but they
couldn't get him moved somewhere more
suitable until he was home and then he
could be assessed so everything was kind
of pinned on him getting home with the
care package and he then would have been
moved um to a they call it like an extra
care scheme where they have nurses on
site that live there they have walk-in
wet rooms so his bathing would have been
easy he could have done that himself or
where he lived he would have needed help
with pretty much everything
um I worked full-time I've got two
children so unfortunately I wasn't able
to you know give give up work to kind of
give them that care and there's and
there's also you know there's just
things that I'm not medically trained to
do
um so I didn't really feel like I could
have provided that for him so he was
ready to go home you know I think he
must have been about four times I got
the call to say oh Dad can go home but
we need to wait for the care package
because he does need care probably three
times a day with his bathing just before
bed and also to come and sort of help
him doing some food I haven't done the
lunch time just to give him some food
um but the other personal care I just
wasn't able to do that yeah no Victoria
it's important to say that because
obviously that is something that's said
a lot when people say well why do you
need a care package you have a family
that can look after you and you've given
us the bigger picture it is not that
simple
um Elliot Roy you were nodding along to
what Victoria was saying there and Roy I
think you whispered to Ellie we hear
this a lot this is a this is a common
problem it is and and Victoria I'm so
sorry to hear that story but it it
encapsulates really the problems that
we're facing now and the NHS did its bit
as as much as it could and then of
course he can't look after people when
they're in their own homes that's the
difficulty that we've got and so we look
to our Partners in Care which are
organized by Social Services what you
were wanting was a package from
domiciliary care
domiciliary care and the care sector
generally has about a 160 000 vacancies
at the moment and getting the care
packages in place is super difficult and
that means then of course that that
person is in bed in a hospital for much
longer than need to be something called
deconditioning takes place where there
they get worse it makes you vulnerable
to things like flu exactly and and as
much as they the hospitals try to avoid
that sort of cross-contamination it's
really very very difficult and and at
the heart of this at the heart of most
of the problems that I'm sure we're
going to hear about this afternoon is
the Victoria example where actually what
we need to fix is social care and and
I'm sure Ellie sees that every day in
her practice Yeah in your practice you
must hear that a lot from families who
you know you're a first Port of Call as
a GP then that patient may go into
hospital and you know people we say it's
difficult to get into hospital it's
difficult to get into GDP but actually
it's difficult to get out of Hospital
absolutely right and people talk now
about patient flow so flowing from
primary care with me
through an ambulance through a hospital
now the other side and it's out the
other side as Victoria's described into
social care that is causing such a
problem with people and it's incredibly
upsetting as well from the human point
of view that this was you know the end
of your Dad's life Victoria and I'm so
sorry that that's sort of how everything
played out and as Roy said you know
Hospital itself is not a good place for
people to be it's great when you're
acutely unwell and my Hospital
colleagues sort people out but then to
sit there and not to have family around
and deconditioning as Roy said allows
unfortunately this very sad end of life
situation to play out and what I think
we'll also hear this afternoon as well
is this story could have been different
in another part of the country we have a
postcode Lottery there could have been a
different social care issue somewhere
else there may have had better staff and
actually it's not a homogenous system
and this didn't have to happen yeah
Victoria thank you so much for speaking
up for
um your family your dad and other
families like you who are going through
the same thing in the National Health
Service